Yeah.
They,
he'll figure out what was the whole experience like being on this ESPN card
because it's a,
that was a historic moment,
much like,
like the Cain Velasquez vs junior dos Santos,
which also stopped the same way.
And that was controversial.
That was not controversial.
The Punch that landed also behind the ear,
same punch,
you know,
like a terminal.
Those things that you,
it just takes your feet up if you've ever fought or if you've ever been in,
got hit in the back of the head,
weird.
Your feet go out from underneath you,
but you're there,
like you're 100% aware of what's going on,
but your balance isn't there.
Then you have another grown man on top of you,
you know.
So of course things are gonna happen.
But uh,
with the ESPN,
it was really cool.
The whole lead up to it.
They film,
they came and filled my late,
they were around a lot.
They did a lot of exposure.
They,
um,
the stuff they put out was really cool.
And then just seeing like our commercial for a fight on national football on
ESPN or for the call it,
you know,
cause college I was going on and then you see the nationals was going on and
you'd see me in like three different commercials than ESPN.
I thought that was pretty cool.
No,
it was amazing.
You know,
I mean,
it really,
uh,
it's cool to see.
It's cool to see that ESPN is embracing the sport and then it's getting into it.
And you know,
there was a lot of hype behind this and you know,
I got ESPN plus I wasn't,
yeah,
no,
I mean I'm not a sports fan.
I don't watch sport.
I don't even know what's happening.
Like where people like,
what are you doing for the Super Bowl?
I'm like,
when's that?
That's exactly what I did.
I don't have time for it,
man.
Um,
I'm a,
I'm a Raiders fan,
but I don't have time to really watch,
you know.
Um,
but yeah,
I mean it's just,
when you think of sports,
you think ESPN.
Yeah.
You really do.
I mean,
it's another level of acceptance in the sports world.
The only thing that kind of bummed me out,
and I should probably clarify this because I talked about this on the podcast,
was the hardy fight.
And not,
not even because I don't think the guy should be fighting or not even because I
think I,
you know,
I don't,
I don't really know what he did in terms of his past.
I know there's a lot of,
there's a lot shit,
right?
I mean,
he was in trouble for something.
There was an appeal and he got off of it somehow.
I don't know,
but I'm only talking about it from a fighting perspective.
You're watching the highest level fights.
You're watching the co main event.
He's just not ready for a co main event.
Like technically no,
no way.
Yeah.
Just see what he rushed out.
He gassed out,
you burn himself out,
Crowder recovered,
and it just,
it's not,
the way it should be is you should have the early fights or people who are
learning the sport.
And then when you get to the last couple of fights,
the Khomeini and the main,
you're supposed to be seeing assassins like you and Henry.
So Huda,
that's what you're supposed to be seeing.
And just crazy thing about our sport is,
is a lot of entertainment behind it as well too.
So if you're hyped up,
you get pushed up the ladder,
maybe you get title fight sooner than you should.
And that's crazy to me because now we're on ESPN now where like we're an
official,
I mean we've been an official support,
but yeah,
it should be more on the level like you're talking about of the actual skill
level and how you're ranked.
I mean cowboy Serone and uh,
Alex kid should have been the a hundred percent main event.
Oh hundred percent.
I was stunned that it wasn't,
they imagine they were on real,
they were on ESPN though.
They wanted to kind of hype up.
He just cam plus it makes sense.
That makes sense for that reason.
Yeah.
But there's another fight they could have put in place of that.
There's 100% and again,
this is not a knock on Crowder or hardy.
There are guys out there doing it.
They're,
they're trying,
they did their job,
did their job.
They're fighting.
I mean not the ending was super unfortunate.
Yeah.
Again,
you don't know whether or not he did it on purpose.
Whether you had a mental,
you're getting punched in the face.
That stuff happens so fast.
Chaos.
Yeah.
I mean especially because he is so new,
right?
Yes.
He hasn't been fighting forever.
Like that stuff just happens like,
oh,
I got them hurt.
Boom.
You know you don't like,
there's things like,
I've even done a practice.
I'm like,
Oh shit dude,
I'm sorry I'm in practice and I did something.
I'm like,
Oh man,
that was stupid.
Like if it happens in a fight,
I'm losing a point.
Like I'm so sorry.
You know like bums me out that this rush to commercialization,
that this,
this rush to trying to get the most eyes on it.
The people that are watching it.
If you watch something where there's two guys who really aren't ready for Co
main event,
you're seeing sloppiness and guys getting out of gas real quick and you're
seeing all the things that you're supposed to learn early in your career so that
by the time you get to a call,
main event,
you know you're a fucking assassin,
you're,
you're locked down and a hundred percent professional.
You're a real elite pro fighter.
That's what I want to see when I'm watching ESPN.
Yeah,
that's what I want to see.
I want to see the best of the best.
You know,
I want to see world class fighters fighting with precision and power and speed
and knowing how to pace themselves.
Guys were the experience.
They've been there before.
They know how to recover from things.
They get cracked,
they know how to lay back.
They know how to hold on.
They know how to do what they need to do in order to win or fight their best
instead of like,
just like you're seeing things.
And so many people are seeing this at this point.
And I feel like we're getting fans now that are more knowledgeable,
like yourself and,
and people aren't seeing this sport and understanding technique now to where
before maybe it didn't matter,
you didn't know what bad technique is now,
you know?
But we get more knowledgeable fans to where they are going to start realizing
like,
what was that like?
Right.
And the last thing you want to see is two heavyweights gassed out.
Yes.
That is the fucking worst.
Yeah.